- What up, world?
It's ya boy Stephen Jackson.
This is "Start, Bench, Cut."
I've been given a category.
One to bench, one to
start, and one to cut.
I'm gonna start whiskey.
I'm gonna bench tequila.
And I'm gonna cut vodka,
cuz I don't drink it.
I'mma cut Tom Brady.
I'mma start Serena Williams,
and I'mma bring Tiger off the bench.
And the reason why I'm starting Serena
is because she's the better athlete
out of all of them.
(blowing air)
I would start
"Tha Carter III," Lil Wayne.
Ah!
F--k it,
I'mma bench "Get Rich or Die Tryin'"
and I'mma cut "Blueprint"
cuz I like all those albums.
I like, that's all one of my favorite albums,
so it was a tough one.
I would cut telepathy.
I would bench super speed,
and I would start super strength.
Nah, I'm not tryna read no minds.
F--k no.
(laughing)
I'm Stephen Jackson,
this is "Start, Bench, Cut."
Check out the podcast "All the Smoke"
on all platforms streaming podcasts
and our video on Showtime
YouTube Basketball.